merci madame amélie cela par l'état
monsieur bernard perrut pour le groupe
l'est républicain
messieurs le premier ministre les
résultats des élections régionales sont
un avertissement pour toute la classe
politique mais plus encore un cri de
désespoir des français face au manque de
résultats de votre gouvernement
sur leur premier sujet de préoccupation
l'emploi le chômage de masse ne cesse
d'augmenter
bien loin de la fameuse promesse ou
l'inversion de la courbe des demandeurs
d'emploi avec 42 milles de puces mois
dernier et que la balle dans 5 7
millions de nos concitoyens inscrits à
pôle emploi avec le temps de noël vient
le temps des promesses de vos promesses
monsieur le premier ministre
mais sont-elles crédibles vous annoncer
un plan massif pour l'emploi mais
combien de fois avons nous entendu ces
mots dans la bouche de votre
gouvernement loin macron patte de
responsabilité cice dialogue social et
bien d'autres toutes ces lois devaient
être une réponse au chômage mais toutes
ont échoué et les français souffrent
considérablement
alors monsieur le premier ministre
qu'attendez vous pour présenter ce grand
plan pour l'emploi
après trois années de pouvoir allez vous
enfin accepté nos propositions sérieuses
et fondée dans ce groupe pour le
développement économique qui contre le
chômage
allez vous tourner le dos aux
d'automatismes au sectarisme se sont
taris que le président de l'assemblée
nationale a lui même manifesté en
ile-de-france pendant cette campagne
régionale et d'ailleurs il n'est pas
parmi nous cet après midi je souhaite
enfin pleine réussite à nos collègues
sur ses bancs valérie pécresse laurent
wauquiez xavier bertrand christian
estrosi
hervé morin pour qui l'emploi et
l'apprentissage seront la priorité dans
leur région danser
ils vont diriger avec conviction
détermination compétence et d'humanisme
si mal débuté la voile et à monsieur le
premier ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le député
tout y était dans votre question le ton
l'amabilité l'ouverture et la modestie
s'il ya une leçon à retenir une nouvelle
fois et que vous l'entendiez pas c'est
ainsi et si les uns les autres pouvons
l'entendre c'est que précisément les
interventions péremptoire celles qui
visent à donner des leçons aux autres
notamment sur cette question de l'emploi
le fait que nous vivons depuis 30 ans
avec le chômage de masse qu d'une
certaine manière nous y avons habitués
le pays
la perte de compétitivité de nos
entreprises
depuis plus de 10 ans née notamment dans
le différentiel avec l'allemagne nous
amène tous tous et c'est aussi le sens
de l'action du gouvernement
sans doute imparfaite la vôtre a dû est
parfaite au cours du quinquennat
précédent
la compétitivité de l'entreprise la
baisse du coût du travail
le soutien à l'innovation et au
numérique
est ce qu'il faut faire plus et
davantage mais bien évidemment parce que
non seulement il ya des inquiétudes sur
la croissance mondiale
mais nous savons où myriam el khomri le
rappelait tout à l'heure que la
croissance que nous avons pas ce qu'il y
a de la croissance et en 2015 1,1 et en
2016 avec une perspective de 1,4 à 1,5
c'est insuffisant des emplois sont créés
et 40000 depuis un an
mais avec l'entrée des jeunes sur le
marché du travail avec la réalité de
l'eau de marché du travail nous savons
que c'est insuffisant donc il faut faire
plus pour faciliter l'embauché pour
aider les entreprises pour former les
chômeurs qui sont les moins qualifiés
faire plus dans tous ces domaines là et
notamment dans l'apprentissage en lien
entre l'état et les régions
voilà monsieur le député essayons les
uns et les autres dans les 18 mois qui
restent d'ici la fin de ce quinquennat
de travailler ensemble
c'est la proposition que je ferai à
l'ensemble des présidents de région dans
les compétences qui sont celles des
conseils régionaux en matière
d'apprentissage de formation
d'innovation de recherche de mobilité et
d'environnement
parce que nous pouvons faire mieux
ensemble et essayons mais c'est un
conseil que je veux bien appliqué
d'abord mais essayons les uns et les
autres de nous parler c'est ce que je
ferai avec les présidents de région
d'éviter tout sectarisme et monsieur le
député vous parliez du président de
l'assemblée nationale
mais j'aurais aimé puisque vous avez
cité un certain nombre de présidents de
région que vous saluer aussi une
nouvelle fois quelle a été l'attitude de
la gauche car nous nous sommes retrouvés
ensemble pour faire barrage à l'extrême
droite ça commence comme ça de lutter
contre le sectarisme
ça veut dire se reconnaître les uns et
les autres et c'est comme ça qu'on fait
progresser et le débat démocratique et
la démocratie et qu'on fait reculer
l'extrême droite
merci monsieur le premier ministre